renoncer enfin un universalisme c'est qu
est ce qu est la prochaine étape
on peut dire la même chose pour la
sécurité sociale pourquoi payer le
dentiste à madame bettencourt
mais l'ailier droit ouais enfin je dis
pourquoi est ce que les milliardaires
aussi en train d'aller chez le médecin
en france et de payer et rembourser par
sécurité sociale c'est un principe
sinon ça fait c'est l'idée qu'on forme
une communauté nationale et que
finalement la solidarité est universel
parce qu'on fait partie d'un même peuple
qu'on paye chacun des des impôts et
qu'on appartient à une communauté
nationale si on brise ce principe là
dans ce cas là bah oui ça la carte ça
veut dire que fille a pu finalement
c'est chacun chacun chacun tirera voilà
à la carte il ya plus cette espèce de
sentiment que multinationale et je crois
que c'est très c'est une pente
dangereuse